the linux file system it's a cryptic
labyrinth of directories defined by the
file system hierarchy standard
navigate through it with the change
directory command cd forward slash drops
you into the root
then with the ls command we can list out
the contents of this directory
first we have the bin directory which
contains binaries or
executables that are essential to the
entire operating system
you can run these binaries from the
command line at any time things like
gzip curl and even the ls command that
we just ran
but confusingly there's also an s-bin
directory it contains system binaries
that should only be executed by the root
user
like mount or delete user many of these
binaries may share common libraries
which are stored in the lib directory
now we also have a usr
user directory with its own bin and
s-bin directories
the binaries or applications here are
non-essential to the operating system
itself and intended for the end user
you'll also notice a local directory
under user
it contains any binaries that you
compile manually to provide a safe place
that won't conflict with any software
installed by a system package manager
all these binaries get mapped together
with the path environment variable
and that's why you can execute them from
any directory in the terminal if you
ever want to know where a binary lives
run which followed by the binary name to
view its full path
in the file system now at some point you
may want to customize the behavior of
the software on your system
the etc directory stands for etc or
editable text configuration
many of these files end in conf and
they're typically just text-based config
files that you can modify
in your editor as an operating system
linux can support multiple users
in the home directory you'll find a
folder named after each user registered
on the system
it contains the files configuration and
software for that user
and you need to be logged in as that
user or as a root user to modify it
notice how the file path is a squiggly
that's your normal starting location
when you open up a terminal session
now let's go back to the root there are
a few more directories here that we
haven't talked about yet
like boot it contains the files needed
to boot the system
like the linux kernel itself then we
have dev which stands for device files
here you can interface with hardware or
drivers as if they were regular files
you might create disk partitions here or
interface with your floppy drive
the op directory contains optional or
add-on software
and you'll rarely interact with it var
contains variable files that will change
as
the operating system is being used
things like logs and
cache files temp is for temporary files
that won't be persisted between reboots
and finally we have the weirdest one of
all
the proc directory is an illusionary
file system that doesn't actually exist
on the disk
but is created in memory on the fly by
the linux kernel
to keep track of running processes this
has been the linux file system in 100
seconds
if you want to see more short videos
like this hit the like button and let me
know what you want to see next in the
comments thanks for watching and i will
see you in the next one